[Risas]
han pasado más de 8 años desde que vimos
los últimos de ryu hayabusa pero a pesar
de todo parece que esta vez sí tendremos
suerte pues probablemente muy pronto
veamos el regreso del ninja gaiden
a principios de año el equipo de team
ninja anunció que no tenían planes de
seguir con la saga de ninja gaiden ni de
un potencial ninja gaiden 4 pues estaban
más preocupados por el desarrollo de
nuevos juegos o con su nueva franquicia
ni o que resultó ser muy exitosa esto
por supuesto fue una noticia
desalentadora para los fans de ninja
gaiden que esperaban el cuarto juego
hace mucho tiempo pero afortunadamente
hace poco team ninja de la mano de tecmo
anunció el ninja gaiden de master
collection una colección de los tres
juegos de ninja gaiden optimizados para
las nuevas consolas esto no hizo más que
emocionar a los fans pues todos pensaron
que era una posible señal de que un
nuevo juego de la saga estuviera en
camino aunque en el momento más allá de
rumores y especulaciones no se dio
ninguna información oficial pero al
parecer puede que sea una oportunidad
después de todo pues hace poco en una
entrevista realizada para la revista
japonesa famitsu
fumihiko yasuda uno de los líderes
actuales de team ninja respondió muchas
preguntas acerca de sus franquicias más
conocidas lo más importante fue cuando
se le preguntó si algún día veremos un
ninja gaiden 4 a lo que ya ayuda
respondió lo siguiente
veremos cómo será la reacción hacia la
master collection y juzgaremos a partir
de ahí si es un éxito es muy probable
que sí honestamente ni siquiera tenemos
un plan aún pero a menudo hablamos
acerca de eso con el equipo después del
desarrollo en llegar en tres supimos lo
que la serie necesitaba así que tenemos
una buena idea de lo que ninja gaiden
representa la naturaleza de los juegos
de acción ha cambiado con el tiempo así
que tenemos que asegurarnos que el juego
evolucione con los tiempos los juegos de
acción puras son muy exitosas estos días
y el número de personas que disfrutan
este tipo de juegos también está
aumentando así que nos encantaría hacer
un llegue de en 4 algún día ryu hayabusa
es muy importante para ti ninja y creo
que este juego es una gran oportunidad
para demostrar el mundo una vez más que
ryu hayabusa es el mejor ninja que ha
existido creo que es muy claro lo que
esto significa el futuro de ninja gaiden
está en nuestras manos si bien no hay
una respuesta absoluta hacia ahora o no
un nuevo juego esto nos deja claro que
team ninja si tiene intenciones de
seguir con la saga y con la colección ya
anunciada lo único que queda es ver si
el juego triunfa o no pues si el juego
genera los suficientes ingresos y tiene
una gran aceptación del público es más
que seguro que comenzarán a trabajar
en ninja gaiden 4 la ya mencionada
master collection es un recopilatorio de
los tres juegos del ninja gaiden con
gráficos y jugabilidad optimizados para
la nueva generación de consolas
lastimosamente según se ha dicho el
juego fuente de los dos juegos
originales se perdió hace mucho tiempo y
no tienen manera de recuperarlo es por
eso que en esta colección no estarán
ninja gaiden black ni el ninja gaiden 2
original sino que contaremos con las
versiones sigma de ambos juegos que
vienen con menos sangre pero con mucho
más contenido dicho esto el juego
incluye ninja gaiden sigma ninja gaiden
sigma 2 inning llegarán 3 resource edge
además tendrá agregado todo el contenido
descargable de los tres juegos como
trajes armas o personajes así que ten
por seguro que el juego tendrá un montón
de contenido si le soy completamente
honesto hubiera gustado que para esta
colección se hubiera hecho tal vez un
remake del primer deniega o que por lo
menos hubieran incluido las versiones
sin censura de los dos primeros juegos
pero ya sabiendo el por qué no lo
hicieron sí estoy bastante emocionado
con este juego pues aparte de ser unos
juegos nos da los que ya conocemos la
saga otra oportunidad de disfrutar
nuevamente todos estos juegos y las
personas que aún no conociendo en llegar
de ahora pueden descubrir ésta
franquicia y de igual manera disfrutarla
así que si queremos un ninja gaiden 4
debemos apoyar la master collection pues
de su éxito depende el futuro de la saga
bueno por eso y porque los tres son los
juegazos contras con quieres ninja
gaiden de master collection saldrá el 10
de junio para xbox playstation steam y
nintendo switch así que ya saben qué
hacer de momento eso es todo lo que se
ha hecho acerca del futuro de ninja
gaiden sé que no es mucho pero es la
única noticia real que hemos visto en
años con respecto a mí llegar en 4 así
que esperemos que esta vez el juego por
fin pueda ver la luz
déjame saber los comentarios qué opinan
de todo esto a la master collection y
del probable regreso de río si se sabe
algo más acerca de todo esto yo los
mantendré informados hasta la próxima
[Música]